hi I'm Joe Navarro and for 25 years I
was chasing spies and today we are
looking at questions that you have asked
on Twitter and this is body language
support
[Music]
from orange flavor don't they don't they
say mirroring body language is a sign of
Attraction yes they do say that but
actually mirroring behaviors are a sign
of comfort if there is psychological
Comfort we will tend to mirror each
other both in Cadence both in sitting
Styles breathing rate and so forth and
so you'll see a couple at a cafe and
maybe they're looking at each other by
both having their hands on their on
their cheek as they look at each other
they're truly mirroring each other once
again because of high psychological
Comfort at Quinn Rochelle asks do power
poses work for interviews also that's an
interesting question you have to
understand what is the purpose of a
power pose you're not there to dominate
when we are in an interview setting
we're actually really in somebody else's
domain rather than a power pose I would
say why don't you use behaviors that
show good manners so turn yielding
letting somebody walk ahead of you using
your hand to Signal where they can sit
versus pointing which is always negative
and being confident using gestures that
are smooth rather than gestures that are
jittery not clearing your throat a lot
not ventilating every time you're asked
a question not acting nervous and and so
forth with questions like this let's get
away from these power poses and let's
look at the poses that say I am
confident I'm reliable I am trustworthy
and that I think is more important from
at Phil five Niner
316885 smirking when confronted with
serious matters
watch out for it it's a disarming body
language used by Liars well I would have
to disagree first of all there is no
single Behavior indicative of deception
do people who smirk do so because
they're lying or they get they're
getting away with something perhaps but
just keep in mind that smirking is
sometimes used when you notice that
somebody has gotten something wrong or
you have something up on on somebody
else what I'd like to do is I like to
note the behavior and if that behavior
makes me feel uncomfortable a I need to
be more careful or B I need to ask more
questions at Jennifer Tilly asks why is
it that when we hear or see bad news we
often cover our mouths Jennifer this
goes back millions of years when we were
surrounded by Predators at all times we
had to communicate silently we developed
three behaviors to deal with that and
the first one was the freeze response if
we saw something that was a threat we
froze why had we run in face of a threat
we would have been chased tripped and
bitten so we learned to freeze everybody
that froze the animal kept going anybody
that ran got eaten they didn't get to
pass on the genes the second Behavior we
did was to cover our mouths number one
Predators listen for people breathing
for animals breathing and by covering
our mouths and our noses we prevented
all these particulates from getting into
the air which then the animals can seek
out and then the third behavior that we
still have is the covering of the neck
that when we are are deeply concerned
when we are troubled when we're bothered
when we're insecure when we feel our
safety is compromised we cover our neck
we cover the super sternal notch this
little area right here three behaviors
millions of years old that have been
brought along with us and help us every
day and so the next time you find
yourself being shocked by something
always remember that's because there was
a feline out there somewhere trying to
pick up on your scent at Mephisto Kerr
ass thinking about practicing my genital
framing techniques when we talk about
genital framing you're talking about
tucking your thumbs inside your pants
humans tend to hide their thumbs when we
have fears or concerns so when it comes
to thumb behaviors we want to keep in
mind that some behaviors say I'm strong
and confident and if you want those then
we use behaviors where the thumbs are
out they are up
and they look powerful rather than
hiding them away inside our pants so at
Liz
88233601 she asks are facial movements
and expressions a part of sign language
I noticed that all signers seem to use
them and the answer is yes not only do
they use the hands to signify specific
letters we know that the face is capable
of nearly 4
000 separate behaviors that can also
communicate and that can give context
emphasis it can serve to describe it can
also serve to articulate the message
that is being given so add Yuki by the
Sea ask doesn't crossing your arms and
body language mean you're being
defensive no
no absolutely no in fact we cross our
arms because it's a comforting Behavior
it's a self-hug and even when you're
angry the fact that you do this is to
self-comfort yourself here you have two
arms pressing against your uh visceral
side which provides a lot of comfort via
the vagus nerve so there's a lot of
myths out there that this is a blocking
Behavior or it's a defensive Behavior it
absolutely it is not it is a comforting
behavior and it needs to be recognized
as such
at Leticia 16 asks what is body language
what is proxemics what is chronemics
what is kinesics what is haptics
proxemics is the study of distances what
we prefer such as our intimate space
personal space social space and public
space and it varies with everybody what
is chronemics chronemics has to do with
with time we all have for instance a
circadian rhythm and the Circadian
rhythm accounts for things like why we
get up in the morning why there's so
many heart attacks for instance early in
the morning why we lose energy late in
the day and so forth what is kinesics
kinesics has to do with how I move my
arm or how I move my fingers and what is
haptics haptics is the study of touch
how we touch ourselves how we touch
others how we touch the screen on our
computers how we touch for instance the
buttons on a jet aircraft this is
studied through tactics at rabbit Justin
asked does peacocking actually work I
remember in the 70s to to be a peacock
meant to always be the center of
attention if he's talking about showing
off if he's talking about wearing
clothing that makes you stand out if
he's talking about behaviors that make
you look different act different or
present differently then obviously it
does our brains are hardwired to detect
anything that deviates from let's say a
norm our brains love novelty but the
question is who's going to be impressed
by it now we know that during the
courtship years about 15 to 25 in almost
all cultures we engage in behaviors that
we might consider peacocking we will
wear different clothing we may wear
makeup we may change the way we walk the
way we wear our hair and and and so
forth so we can say that these things
work but they work within limits if you
go too far afield you can literally
become an object of ridicule uh if if
you go overboard at dressmail
biosass does nonverbal communication
affect the virtual consult experience I
have to say that the virtual world it
may be a good way to collect information
that in no way it can approximate what
we can see when we're in the same room
it does impact on our ability to
communicate effectively across all
cultures the power of the shaman the
power of the healer is based on four
things the first one is the visual right
so the shaman usually dresses
differently performs differently has
different attire in Western medicine you
have the white lab coat and you have the
stethoscope you have the visual and then
you have the vocal and so you have the
intonation of the voice some sort of
incantation a dance or a performance and
the words are meant to to somehow heal
you and then lastly you have the actual
application of the medicine through
bodily contact touch and so forth think
about what the virtual environment does
it limits the visual it limits the vocal
it limits the verbal and it limits the
haptic my fear is that in a virtual
world you don't get to share these
things so thank you again thank you for
your questions hope to get some more in
the future you've been watching body
language support
[Music]